so writing directing all these things
but you are still acting we saw you in
the girl and spiders well yes and that
was a big kind of action movie well I am
well the reasons I want to do it was
because it was you know had an action II
element yes magic element and it was
actually gonna be they told me I could
do it that I was gonna be in this fight
scene that's the first time I've ever
done a fight so I'm sure you've done
plenty but um I was excited the idea of
him being in this fight scene they said
um ok so what's happened you've got this
young son and they says Satine breaks
into the house where you're staying and
you're in the bathroom we did kick
getting ready for bed and the assassin
comes in you know and I'm like ok great
and I sort of defend my son yeah they
all right well know what we want you to
do is we want you to cower in the corner
right so what happens the assassin does
he anyway
well don't worry someone's gonna tackle
him and I'm like right ok and the guy
playing the assassin was your height and
I'm 6 foot 7 and the person tackling the
assassin was Claire Foy the crown who's
just over 5 feet tall I'm like right and
and I just cower in the corner they're
like yeah and I listen I'm all for you
know empowering women having women it
has strong characters in movies but
there is nothing more humiliating than
being an Englishman cowering in the
corner while the Queen clicks someone's
out
I said I said could I at least just for
my own dignity could I at least just
maybe I just dry throw one punch they're
like alright we'll allow you to hit the
guy with something and then he'll just
swat you away I'm like alright another
thing that they gave me to hit him with
because we're in a bathroom was one of
those sanitary towel bins so um yeah
it's not the second future so when you
cower you're still quite big yeah I mean
whilst cowering still bigger than Claire
Foy yet the fight went on forever in the
movie and so I've just got to be lying
there the whole time my phone
[Music]